Find the perimeter
of this hexagon.
So the perimeter just means
the distance around the
object, or if you add up all of
the lengths of the sides of
the object, so we're going to
add up all of the lengths of
sides of this hexagon, and a
hexagon is just a six-sided
geometrical shape like this.
So to find the perimeter, we
just need to find the distance
around the hexagon, which is
going to be the sum of all of
the lengths of the sides.
So the perimeter is going to be
24-- so how many of these
do we have?
We have one, two, three, four,
five, six 24's, which makes
sense, because a hexagon
has six sides.
So we're going to have-- let
me write this a little bit
bigger-- 24 plus 24 plus 24 plus
24 plus 24-- and that's
five 24's-- plus 24.
So let's add them all
at the same time.
We could've done it piece by
piece, but let's just go
straight ahead.
So let's go first to
the ones place.
So 4 plus 4 is 8, 8 plus 4 is
12, 12 plus 4 is 16, 16 plus 4
is 20, 20 plus 4 is 24.
And now we're in
the tens place.
2 plus 2 is 4 plus 2 is 6 plus
2 is 8 plus 2 is 10 plus 2 is
12 plus 2 is 14.
So the sum of these
six 24's is 144.
That is the perimeter.
And when we learn
multiplication, if you haven't
learned it already, you could've
down this simpler.
You just say you have six 24's,
so this would actually
be a multiplication problem
of 6 times 24.
If you don't know how
to do that just yet,
don't worry about it.
You can just add them all up.
You get 144.